وابدا معك السفير جيمز
جفري رساله كما
يتفق عدد من الاطراف سواء سياسيه او
عسكريه ارسلت الى واشنطن ما عنوانها
برايك انا لست متاكدا انها رساله تحديدا
لان ايا من هذه الهجمات التي تجاوزت الئه
والتي استهدفت مصالح
امريكيه تم تنظيمها من قبل ايران
وتم وشنت من قبل اذرع لها هي تمثل تهديدا
لا ارى بالضروره انه تصعيد في حقيقه الامر
الامر يشير ان اداره بايدن لم تتعلم الدرس
درس ردع ايران الامر يتعلق بايران لا
يتعلق بغزه ولا يتعلق بالفلسطينيين او
القض الفلسطينيه بل ايران فقط ودورها في
المنطقه اذا لم تقم واشنطن بردع ايران
بشكل
فعال مثلا كما حصل في قتل قاسم سليماني او
ايضا كما حرب الناقلات في عام
1988 سنرى المزيد من هذه الهجمات وما الذي
يمنع واشنطن من ردع طهران كما
تقول
ضرب اهداف
اساسيه ايرانيه سا اوصي
مثلا استهداف ل مثلا مقرات للحرس الثوري
الايراني واذا قلت انه سيكون ربما اذا ماز
كان هنالك المزيد من الهجمات ربما تتم يتم
استهداف مجمع نانز هذا سيوقف الهجمات
الايرانيه لكن اعتق
انه كما قلت تجاوزت الهجمات الايرانيه
المئ ولقد راينا هذه الهجمات تحصل قبل
السابع من اكتوبر كانت بدات وبدات بهجمات
صغيره وبعد ذلك از ازدادت وتيرتها وكبر
حجمها